une production du studio sfr nous sans
filtre l'oeuvre de gaston parce qu avec
deux invités à ces super content avec
moins d'hommes plantes
vous savez qu'on loue le studio si vous
ne savez pas vous l'apprends maintenant
ça vient avec tout l'équipement avec la
technique on s'occupe de tout vous
n'avez qu'à venez vous asseoir et faire
votre contenu pour plus d'informations
et communaux sans filtre pas de casta
commercial gmail.com cette semaine
bigbee cette semaine en russie où dix
belfort un gars vraiment inspira à
suivre sur les réseaux sociaux est
partout en fait un goût s'entraîne
kiffant qui est beaucoup plus fort et
beaucoup plus seul athlète de niveau
mondial qui se trouve à être en chaise
roulante c'était vraiment un plaisir de
par lui ai parlé avec lui de motivation
de dépassement de soi et aussi de la
réalité des personnes en chaise roulante
sous tous ses angles
c'était vraiment une belle robe guest
mais justement aller dans la
conversation va le dire un petit mot
pour nous remercier nos sponsors en fait
oui le podcast d'aujourd'hui est
présenté par alta science quitte
l'entreprise de recherche contractuelle
spécialisée dans les essais cliniques a
été fondée en 9 92
ici au québec leurs locaux sont à
montréal qu'est ce qu'ils font en fait
qui soutiennent la commercialisation de
médicaments génériques donc des copies
ou des versions moins chères mais tout
aussi efficace des médicaments que vous
connaissez bien qu'ils sont déjà sur le
marché
il participe aussi à mettre sur le
marché des nouveaux médicaments
piochez la recherche en science la
recherche clinique c'est super important
snetap essentiel en fait au
développement de nouveaux médicaments
puis ces médicaments d'après ce
on a un besoin donc c'est important de
participer et de soutenir la recherche
comment ça fonctionne en fait qu'elle
allait sur leur site web où les appeler
pour voir l'éventail de tests qui sont
proposés vous choisissez celui qui
conforme à vos intérêts et si vous
répondez aux critères d'admissibilité
vous allez être choisi pour aller passer
un séjour en clinique ou ce que vous
allez faire les deux sens clinique vous
avez les repas gratuits
vous avez un dortoir vous avez
l'internet vous avez la télé hd mieux
mieux mon attarderons à verdon il ya une
indemnisation monétaire de milano à 9000
dollars par don tout dépendant de
l'étude que vous choisissez pour avoir
plus d'informations dirigez-vous au
triple w points gault alta point ca ou
appelez au 5 1 4 3 8 052 2 0 merci la
gagne d'alto sciences de commencer des
podcasts
le podcast cette semaine et présenté par
mme aux amish et mainstage vous avez
aucune dé ce qu'ils viennent juste de
lancer ils viennent de lancer le lower
cats pourrait 0 si vous attendiez avant
de vous acheter l'amour 3.0 envisage
pour chaussures là ils viennent de
changer encore une fois la game qu'est
ce qui nous vaut dans le land art 4.0 la
principale features et que vous pouvez
augmenter et diminuer la longueur des
poils qui reste ça veut dire que si
comme dom votre moustache vous fait
augmenter réduire pour laisser la
moustache longue et réduire le reste
vous aussi allumé et fermer la lumière
une nouvelle feature look est un petit
peu plus moderne d'un petit peu plus
league c'est vraiment de la bombe mais
c'est pas la seule nouveauté chez
mindscape d'hommes expérimentés que
d'autres nouveautés moi j'adore le nord
3 0 puis le 4.0 j'aime encore plus mais
je suis autres cool quand tu as vraiment
le
la leçon le sac attaque tels jaime su le
faire à la lame vraiment le certains
diront que joue avec le feu mais c'est
vraiment à la lame que je préfère ce
courant soit électrique et bien
maintenant minsk est pas le produit pour
les gens comme moi les gens qui militent
à se tait le crunch est vrai alors c'est
un round 3 lames fait pour ce vraiment
fait l'essai s'essayer au moindre risque
de se faire mal loti avec un
heureusement qu il vraiment 10 anni pour
so i les produits qui viennent indique
c'est le crop gel à orange l arrosage
consommées puis qu'après ça facilite
puis aussi le crop exfolier terre qui
vont réduire les chances de poils
incarnés et et quand ça repousse pas que
ça ça reste prégnante d'apps a fait dire
ça fait mal le ce a réduit ce risque
donc des produits faits sur mesure pour
les gens comme moi qui est fait en un
code promo pour vous qui le sans filtre
en amont pour 20% de rabais et le
shipping gratuit fake sauter l'actu dès
demain je sais pas quoi vous dire de
plus
merci de m'indiquer sauter là dessus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
yes ou disaro l'on tourne
salut salut merci d'être là je veux
juste je commençais en racontant
l'anecdote qui viennent se passer parce
que je trouve qu'une anecdote qui en dit
long sur une personne en jour son e-mail
de pamela qui s'occupe de la fondation
de walter altergo 1000e
on en reparlera plus tard l'ami localise
faire un festival j'imagine mais c'est
plus un événement pour rassembler tout
le monde qui ont une difficile
limitations physiques ou limitations
pour faire du sport ou les poussaient
fort des activités physiques toi exact
que ce cadre que pamela m'écrire pour me
dire et où dit il est arrivé mais vous
avez pas d'ascension moindre occasion
plus et on en à l'ascenseur ici avec
nous il doit elle doit pas être là
finalement s'appeler pleut tu me dis
salut odyssée pht août je me répondent
je souffre finalement message vocal
après puis c'est juste c'est toi qui rit
en dix ans et en même temps un podcast
vient pas d'ascenseur jeunes montée des
marches finalement on après ton monte
combien de palier de marchands étaient
six étages sérieux cet âge si c'est pour
le tac
quand on est là pas prêt il crie ton nom
c'est 7 h de marche sauf que tu me dis
un rien céder j'arrête en tabarnak de
développent sur reach prochain avec un
live c'est normal que quand je me rends
à une situation save as jamais être
comme j'imagine pas ce que j'ai dit a
toujours des marquis a toujours fait
toujours y surgissent au rang d'idole
faut que j'en ris le papier je te vois
arriver sous la pluie en chaise roulante
europe
c'est un mardi normal
c'est fou c'est assez pour que je
mettais ma musique me dictait la musique
qui je roulais jj manquements légers psa
comme douagui ça m'a apporté un autre
alors j'ai fallait que je retourne dans
mes pas dans les pas puis lafarge accuse
une autre rue et que ce soit plus plus
que quatre minutes mais écologique très
amis avec moi j'ai bien relax
après on est je me suis dit je dois
m'attendre
excuse-moi pas prescrite
est-ce que ça a toujours été ça pour toi
toujours resté positif dans ces
situations là je vous ça a été plus
difficile au début mais ton [ __ ] ça
c'est le fait que j'ai grandi avec mon
handicap
c'est une bonne question de positif
c'est juste une question de problème
comment je peux le résoudre puis veut
pas s'il ya toujours prendre ça sert à
quoi tout le temps pour le même problème
soit force à force de le faire je trouve
que je trouve quelque chose de drôle je
trouve quelque chose de positif
là-dedans je pense que oui je t'ai
toujours positif mais en même temps
c'est ma vie avant qu'on entend au nom
du site et y parlait de ce qui est
souvent dit mettons pour la perception
des gens tout c'est quelque chose qui
est bien normal pour toi je te ma montée
des marches tous les gens sont comme ben
voyons dont mike goss a pas de bon sens
c'est comme un souci pour moi c'est moi
c'est mon quotidien est ce que tu as
l'impression que pour toi des
limitations sont sont moins pires que ce
que les gens projet tout ce que les gens
perçoivent comme antoine comment toi tu
t'aperçois mon handicap versus comment
moi je vois moi moi je le vis ouais je
trouve que moi mon handicap leur passé
oui oui ça me limite physiquement mais
c'est pas ottawa comme tu dis c'est
maintenant il ya des marches c'est ce
que moi je compterai habile comme
personne en photo mais c'est en même
temps une petite marche puis chiffre qui
est certain à 95% des patients fauteuil
dans son cadre
merci mais toi tu vas faire au nom faut
que je la vends non faut que en ont ils
dit en discuter ou est-ce que tu as
besoin de ce que on veut trop aidé on
veut trop protéger les personnes en
fauteuil roulant je pense qu'à oublier
un certain sens est quatre gars qui
étaient en fauteuil ou même en béquilles
ou aveugles quoi que ce soit 3,5
l'inclination de l'aider parce que tu
penses que sa vie est extrêmement déçu
dans le moment qui doit en fait oui
absolument mais ce site en asie par
exemple il ya des choses que toi tu
remarques que moi je remarquerai par
exemple c'est maintenant sûr il nous
faudra deux de métro mais que palace en
soit je connaissais pas accès j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya quand même encore
beaucoup de chemin à fabas à londres
j'appelle toujours seul de sac le sac de
l'handicap parce que le fait qu' il n'y
a rien dapd et les personnes fortes
relations moins clean et d y aller sur
son moindre inégalée vous les moi
j'appelle ça des people vous les bipèdes
voulait vu que vous avez pas habitués de
le bouder les voir donc à vous envoyer
voler trop vous êtes sur ce saut
compenser sur le fait que vous en voyez
pas prive les les aider mais ça ne me
plus que d'autre chose
il arrivait toujours en sarthe 2 et si
ça nous nuit puisque d'autres choses on
attend ça - vouloir aller à les rendre
publique sa voix se brise puis est ce
que le fait que vous êtes maintenant une
station de métro qui est pas
d'accessibilité ce que le fait que vous
avez moins tendance à vouloir y aller
fait qu'il ya moins de lumière sur la
problématique complexe parce que enfin
la journée si je dis à quelqu'un
oui mais vous avez besoin de remplir
s'ils me proposent juste prix plafond en
photo g
oui s'il ya six a pas de rampe on
propose a dit mais elle si le monsieur
ne répond mais il ya personne qui vient
lui va pouvoir voir l'art est la
nécessité de mettre m natation matin
trente six pour s'agitent en a plusieurs
mais passer aux personnes à les
personnages aient pensé avec les mighty
poussette
pensez à le tig est séquencée l'âge fait
comme ça il va plus réalisé en weppes et
est ce que ce serait
bénéfique pour tout le monde verser
juste dire penser aux personnes en
fauteuil roulant ouais parce qu'ils vont
de ça mais on n'a pas beaucoup on les
voit pas parce qu'il y en a qui y en a
du monde et dans la construction qui
m'ont dit face mais il ya j'en vois
jamais convoqué c'est envoyé s'ils
viennent pas là ça me trottait étaient à
chaque jour et il y avait des gens en
fauteuil roulant qui a gardé sa démarche
on ferait là qu'il faut faire c'est la
raison pourquoi tout le monde en parle
en ce moment c'est parce que moi je moi
j'ai une voix une voix forte puis
j'entends j'aime ça je cherche je
cherche je cherche il on essaye de
trouver des solutions non on en parle
encore parce que on voit qu'il ya
quelqu'un en fauteuil roulant qu'il veut
mais c'est pas vrai que c'est juste moi
j'ai des amis que j aimerais sans
utiliser le métro william récent est
farcie vide immense à faire ce geste
comme sont gênés où ils vont pouvoir
citoyen pour y parvenir ils vont user ce
est ce que est ce que c'est quelque
chose que toi tu te fais qu d'avoir le
sentiment de de topline trop c'est de
dire moi je veux pas être un fardeau je
porte ces faits que je veux juste le
temps est requis pour parler de ces
choses là je trouve que même quand
j'étais petit je pense que chez une
meilleure personne pour être en fauteuil
roulant parce que ma personnalité fait
que je suis pas gêné oui ça je trouve
que même cachet petit jeu c'est pourquoi
moi je ferais pas hélas comme moi je
peux pas si au primat je me rappelle y
avait une marge pour aller a écrit mais
les la rampe et est comme l'eau bord
loin loin loin loin puis on me demande
toujours d'aller à la raison les grands
contours mecacci petit je joue avec mes
amis et tout de suite ça je me suis dit
pourquoi moi je dois faire ça parce ça
puis à chaque jour je demandais la
question puis je pense qu'ils ont
installé une rampe quelque chose après
juste à côté de sakho c
s'arrête des points mais ça me donne
l'impression que dans dans ta vie parce
que j'ai vu le toit des visions prévu de
se c'est toujours malgré les difficultés
le positif à brioude oui oui je trouve
que même si en situation il ya plus
qu'une façon de voir si un travail oui
ça oui ça paye de musique mais avoir
toujours trouvé comment contourner le
prends parce que si tu dois être là
quand même
tu vois pas avancé sur moi à force
france à force d année de faire deux
quotidiens avoir un problème puis le
réseau dit tout ça m'a comme donner un
sourire en face parce que j'ai réussi
aujourd'hui si je pense à tout ce qui
peut les prendre que j'ai vécu je suis
fier enfin la journée les prochains mais
c'est juste une anecdote que j'ai pas
encore rencontré encore sont à force de
pratiquer en france puis à gauche qui
est possible dans la vie sont ça comme
ça comme ça passe ça fait un lien que je
serai tout le positif mais pas toujours
heureux ce soit que je dirai tout est
possible c'est pas de la rue c'est juste
de voir les soissons et d'heures qu'il
ya une façon de règle de la grille
qu'est-ce qui se veut dire tes potes
toujours et était dessus et pas toujours
heureux j'imagine comme toutes les
plantes grasses et la france et sur les
médias sociaux une des raisons pourquoi
je j'ai mort ce n'est que wish souriant
wish ici mais je peux toujours juste
parce que je veux pas mais l'illusion
que la vie est toujours parfait parce
que si moi j'ai toujours eu est parfait
mais ça nous sommes il faut que les
personnes en fauteuil roulant la belle
vie quoi
il ya même du monde qui me pose la
question le chapeau assorti un axe fort
tout venant
la vie quoi à gauche avec mon fauteuil
roulant mais comme je trouve le fait que
attend j'ai perdu mon train de tourner
autant le fait que je je monte
oui j'ai une ce qui t'est ou mal gré mal
gré marc bellemare ça montre que oui oui
très positif même si ce même si ta
journée c'est la merde ce combat j'ai
pas besoin de sourire pour montrer
positif j'aime parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de monde qui me dis à ta vie en fauteuil
c'est cool et tous non cousin je
souhaite à personne est en fauteuil et
il ya du monde qui posa qui sont très
contents cities enfants sans faute et
non comme est en faute et enfin la
journée c'est quelque chose de presse
patrice jeu prédatrice mais c'est pas
quelque chose que je souhaite à
quelqu'un ouais mais si tu oses à sa
pizza que certains demandent c'est ça
que je veux mettre la nuance
ouais ouais j'suis un tramway puis le
fait que je n'arrête pas de montrer dans
les médias sociaux que je tombe que je
fais ma cage que cache pas parfait ça
démontre une réalisme ça démontre mieux
oui je garde le sourire oui mais il ya
quand même des journées que 6 pts 9
je voyais une vidéo qui fait que tu as
fait
ou est-ce que tu essaies défunt c'est
une saleen l'intérêt de faire un stand
sur un ballon de basket qui sur un an
les commandes d'apple genre de rachat de
barres parallèles sur le sud ouest et
sur un ballon de basket le te montrer
comme quelques-uns secteur fait le genre
5,6 été rendu à peu près jusqu'à 40 kg
enfin réussit pas sauf que c'est full
tilt de voir le automatiquement fasciné
impressionné de voir que même si tu
tombes qu'un défaut tombe bien il le
titre tombe du tram ans à 3 puces étant
très bleu tabarnak tomber placé genre
folle mais tu leur fais quand même la
relève quand même puis même si à la fin
tu l'as pas parfaitement comme tu
voudrais le fasse tout à marquer progrès
que jobs lire et on avance pour passer à
autre chose qui est une mentalité que je
trouve débile tant pis ça fermait dans
la perspective beaucoup d'enfants -
depuis que depuis qu'on sait qu'on va te
recevoir russie puis que picon que je
connais ton existence plus que je
regarde tu étais réseaux sociaux c'est
c'est l'effet que ça fait que ça me fait
c'est de relativiser vraiment beaucoup
le négatif qui m'arrive dans ma vie
parce que je me dis crise quelqu'un qui
a un handicap comme le tien est capable
de rester tout le temps positif
d'attaquer la vie à tous les jours mon
rythme j'ai un staff négatives qui
m'arrivent sam chèques pendant une
journée complète puis je me dis je me
dis faut que je change mon maïs et puis
ça me fait du bien pour vrai de tripes
de voir ce que tu fais c'est vraiment un
beau verbe arcis pourrait ça me fait
toujours chaud au coeur quand le monde
me dit waouh
ce qui s'est beaucoup ce fut moi j'aime
vraiment que c'est parce que pour moi
c'était moi c'est un homme normal non
mais c'est seul sait si chamas puis le
fait que tu étudies world tu tu regardes
les fêtes puisque war moi j'ai une
petite fille je peux je peux la petite
prime c'était prendre un droit non je
m'engage et je sais pas s'il ya beaucoup
qui vois pourquoi moi je chiale de ma
vie quand toi tu es si c'est non tu as
droit d'avoir des preuves mais bon en
même temps braderie c'est sadrack la
tracklist
je suis en train de faire de me balancer
son ballon c'est une beau parallèle en
stand ça sans fil y rien puis j'ai
attaqué au dessus de cinq employeurs
puis j'ai pas réussi mais d'après à foix
et la 50e fois était différent ouais
j'ai appris qu'en neuf fois comme à
tomber et la 50e point c'était c'était
peut-être 20% dès qu'est ce que je veux
vraiment faire j'ai appris comment bien
monté ok avec contrôle là demain quand
je vois l'attaqué je sais quoi comment
bien monter son jeu d'attaqué nos façons
comment bien équilibré quand je suis
michelin c'est si vraiment j'avais
prononcé des courageux pataky le monde
comme ça mais je trouve que on abandonne
trop vite quand on fait quelque chose
puis on est trois gars qui fait du sport
qu'on ait trop de kiev qui a fait
beaucoup de sport qu on était jeunes
segi un parfait au début non c'est loin
d'être parfait
après un journée qu'on a on a on a
commencé à jouer affirmé sport puis la
dernière journée
c'était carrément différent pourquoi
parce qu'on n'a pas arrêté on a eu des
mauvais journée on a eu des journées
qu'on s'attelle au pic puis finalement à
sa réalité quand même
mais regardez regardez comment ça nous a
forgé en tant que personne c'est pour ça
que quand il ya quelque chose rapport
oublie les 10 parfois et qui est à paris
sipa gaffe était là on dira peut-être la
12e peut-elle à présent j'ai toujours
saddam et riche peut-être même jamais en
fait mais qu'y voir une progression
quand même ouais c'est peut-être que ton
objectif final du tyran ne jamais sauf
que toutes les procédures soient
offertes pour te rendre jusqu'à eux pour
essayer de te rendre ça aurait dû se
dire mais ça c'est une mentalité qui qui
est vraiment j'ai l'impression propre
aux sports je pense que c'est plus
facile à forger qu'anti sportif parce
que l'exemple et dans ta journée de
sport repas jeux mais je pense que tout
le monde le vit comme un artiste il va
pas il va pas un niveau parmi eux il y
aura t il son envoûtant son oeuvre
je pense que lui valent réaliser plus
tard mais nous c'est vraiment dans le
moment après c'est un petit animal
performer secondes d'un mal profond
d'être ici ça c'est là que ton cerveau
non régis a fait voir ce chef un prof
qui a une journée de qui plus ou moins
où je peux importe qui je pense que
c'est tout le monde ne vit juste les
sportifs on dit à chaque jour dans une
façon rapide moins grande que moi
vraiment vraiment c'est l'espace exemple
parfait de c'est impossible de bondues
ça demande un travail sur des années un
travail quotidien tout le temps tout le
temps puis ça ça apprend la persévérance
à toujours vouloir se dépasser de cépie
puis en bout de ligne dans le sport même
si tom et on de l'adversaire compétition
ces résultats toi même le comtois moi
même à chaque jour compte que tout bouge
tes propres limitations des preuves
c'est mettons je peux si je peux pas me
comparer à celui qui mesure six pieds
cinq lampes sintis ou maison maugis très
exemple l'auteur s'appuie cette
croissance c'est chacun près moi où je
suis rendu je peux te faire mieux et
s'est dit victime et on boit je repense
à ces enveloppes allons tenter m'a fait
tinter méfier des finances pop je pense
quand même que tu mets ton ma mère c'est
tout le temps telle importance et
améliorer te surpasser de seppi en bout
de ligne
bowling c'est ce par belinda avis est ce
parce que ça n'est qu'à toi on vient
tout au monde avec 1 puissent être les
cheveux comment dire le métier si
mettons tout sans diplôme et un autre si
d'autres choses mais non c'est toujours
depuis la seule chose qu'on ne le voit
la seule chose qu'on peut faire c'est
essayer que chacun nos forces aussi
joindre aux forces puis c'est d'essayer
davo de faire le maximum de ce qui nous
est donné
j toujours à mes amis j'ai toujours j'ai
dit une fois j'ai toujours à mes amis
que c'est toi toujours pour toi toi
maintenant on t'a donné des cartes toi
on a donné des caps mohammad anis mais
carte juste parce que moi j'ai les
cartes de uno ça pose le jeu pas bon je
vois pas jouer à propos
je vais utiliser mes cartes avec le gîte
kim avec ce que tu vas y tu le cites il
m'a donné par ce garçon qui joue avec
les cartons a donné quoi exactement faut
que tu joues et merci beaucoup c'est la
partie jouée avec les casques ouais ce
que tu as dit toi de mon choix en plus
j'ai dit tout paraît qu'il a parfois
tenté avec les amis les ailes
oui c'est vrai je vois jamais gagné au
poker que des camerounais mais il y en a
qui avec des cartes moins bonne je
tellement bien tellement fort qu'ils
peuvent battre quelqu'un qui est des
cartes au départ mais qui ce qu'en dit
oui ces cartes à puce et comment bien
utiliser tes forces je pense locaux chan
plus parce que j'ai un ami qui a peu de
bruit mais il faut que cela se fait
qu'après il faut que ce fait que rif est
il fait ça avec ses jambes le griffer
des backflips 1 comme il s'exile -
beaucoup de soigner les noirs les flip
les flip je veux faire ça parce qu'il
trouve ça vraiment cool qui fait des
chapeaux baclet peut s'attraper
pourrais-je ans revient même pas belle
s'est pas fait
il s'est promis canidés je vois je pense
que le fait que vous avez tout comme
tous vos membres le fait que vous avez
pas de problème en tant que tel vous
prenez ça pour acquis et parce que mon
ami pourrait vous le voyez aller c15
qu'est-ce qui fait puis moi je vois sa
fille comme telle mais j'aime ça après
je vois un ami que lui à tous ses
membres et où puis je dis est on veut
dire faire x ou y
ah non j'ai pas le temps aux non je me
semble je pense pas que je suis bon
cousin le grand fauteuil de la bande
vidéo laisse canada avec lui qui va
utiliser tes jambes aux pertes est pas
bon au début c'est pas grave je trouve
sympa j'aime pas je ne sais pas comment
l'exprimer mais il ya certaines
mentalités que beaucoup de monde que je
veux en que je veux éliminer parce que
je peux je trouve ça joue sa plaquette à
tout membre qui tire pas
tester d'autres choses nouveau parce que
tu penses rappelle bongo dit l'un d'eux
s'y limiter des ex créneau promis
mutation entraînant ses seuls cet apport
de tapper de de mal performé la première
fois oui bon enfant c'est quoi le pire
qui peut arriver c'est exact ses
méthodes sa datation d'un confort tu vas
laisser quelque chose qui quitte jamais
ses coûts sur le cycle permettant jeté
un voile sur un pan am et en évitant
l'escaladé
puis on commence les listes des
débutants qui t'arrive pas monter ton
porte en tout cas c'est pas grave on va
apprendre qui dans la mise à tenet
contre quoi qu'est ce qui te manque un
kia ce week-end injuste s'entraîner ça
chez nous équipe-là besoin de corruption
il faut qu on veut juste apprendre à
tenir des trucks avec juste mon doigt
puis on va juste le pratiquer peu après
la prochaine fois on va essayer de
rester le second d'après ton en seconde
walker gratte une victoire leur faut
faire quelque chose d'autre mais on
dirait que chaque pas vouvry
non mais pas vous mais le monde il ya du
monde qui veulent performer à 100% ou ne
veulent pas ils veulent pas l'essayer
puis ça ça m'énerve au nombre de fois
que que je sais j'ai craint beaucoup ma
date mais on est là pour ça j'ai
commencé les échecs en décembre
apparemment c'est 1000 c'est la
population générale
ok j'ai commencé à s'en faire c'est vrai
on va bon j'ai utilisé mon roi pour
attaquer deux contrats pour le monde à
la maison voilà
mais je me suis dit est correct c'est
bienvenu 66 après péter gens j'ai
continué je continue je continue j'ai
perdu beaucoup de game jeu quand je vais
au dessus de 500m puis là je suis rendu
à 606 j'ai dépassé mon but de 500 parce
que c'est huguette à 7.50 à dix points
c'est vraiment méchant comme système
mais j comme on est quand même en avril
puis se rendent à 6 ans mon but c'est
moral à 650 d'ici un mois
26 ans 50 d'ici un mois puis pourrait
même si je pars ce pas grave j'ai c'est
quelque chose de nouveau
je pense j aime ma structure depuis
qu'il ya quatre ans oui c'est pour ça je
comprends pas pourquoi on a pas si pas
de perdre si peur de mal performé mais
l'escaladent si les choses et challenger
que j'ai faite parce que tu arrives tu
arrive devant un problème 9 juin au bloc
neuf hectares est devenu un club qui a
une fille à côté de moi qui ai tout
petit qui est définitivement moins forte
que moi qui qui est probablement même
qui c'est qui qui en terme de force
relative - forte - la fed problème la
place rachetant au plus toute seule et
simple
la débâcle après si je passe la journée
complète à checker le problème des
affaires qui cache la forêt mettre mon
pied longue que je met mon avance plus
tu le fais encore plus à chaque fois tu
vois peut-être un coach de plus loin
quand je les plus loin de 40 arrivée au
bout quand arrive au bout le c'est pas
tes pas limité par ta force a en fait
laissé seul est le truc c'est genre
c'est vraiment juste la technique c'est
il faut pas que tu le prennes personnel
il faut juste continuer à le faire si je
commets les gars plus forts deux fois
plus fort que moi qui sont même parfois
les scarabées
ouais je connais du monde trois fois
plus faible que moix encaveurs de faire
des affaires descarie que je range à la
fin ça c'est pas de limitations
physiques moi c'est vraiment
comme si ces challengers faire sauf
qu'en même temps c'est comme un
challenge qui est vraiment le fun pour
eh oui parce que c'est toi c'est petit
si demain dans le timée la lampe puis
personne d'autre que toi le citoyen doit
savoir si tu tombes sa cause de toi tu
réussisses à cause de toi
ouais sautaprats ça prend vraiment c'est
vraiment fort depuis le moment que j'ai
commencé à lescar
j'ai vite réalisé ma force ah bah voilà
c'est pour ça je crois de réussir comme
des techniques parce que s'il ya des
places que tu as besoin des gens oui
mais non ça veut juste dire qu'il faut
juste que je trouve d'autres mots de
façon de la droite façon de le faire
puis il ya des places que j'essayais
puis stressant pour ce qu'ils ont dit ça
pour ça faut que si zélande
j'ai réussi à alpha sans les gens puis
deux le challenge est de le faire sans
les gens puis la majorité du monde façon
carrée de fer avec son argent mais on
dirait que dès que dès que tu vois que
quelqu'un est capable de faire
s'il fait aussi tousser comment qui est
découvert cette passion pour le sport
mais tant pis comment comment c'est
arrivé mais consiste chronologie
toujours été un enfant très active this
multijeux marchait pas je voulais
partout je me prenais tout le temps puis
on sera au primat c'est l'histoire avec
la marche
il y avait une fois que je me suis dit
est ce que c'est qu'un le sauté j'ai
j'ai fait j'ai tombé devant moi comme
enfant je me suis dit je vais le refaire
je le referais
puis on dirait l'adrénaline de se
déclencher une flamme en moi pour faire
la descendante
c'est une marche comme de 2,3 ce que la
hauteur d'entre eux trois puis je me
suis dit qu'un outil faute est à 6 ans
est-ce que je garde les sautés pitt et
au début tout mais n'en fait pas sa ba
piaf à force de tomber
j'ai quand même appris de thomas bien
faire un petit boum j'ai réussi puis
deux puis je fais je le fais je le fais
ça comme déclencher quelque chose en moi
que je
faire du sport je veux faire quelque
chose qui va bouger j'ai commencé le
basket en fauteuil roulant puis ça ça
allume x alimenter ma flamande - puis
voir page suivante d'autres choses parce
que 4 5 ans versailles 17 ans je voulais
faire ce que je peux m'entraîner si
farce
j'ai vite réalisé que j'étais bon à
l'entraînement c'est très fort puis à
force de faire ça on voudrait que ça m'a
donné le goût de faire d'autres choses
rendez à 18 ans j'essaie de faire du
trapèze j'ai essayé de contacter ses
mollets pour voir qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire plus j'essaie les trucs plus ça
donne le goût de continuer parce qu'il
ya tellement de sports différents qu'on
parle pas que je n'ai pas encore essayé
que je veux essayer que oui vraiment
maintenant tu fais du foot du basket
haut niveau le chesnay provincial
canadien pète ait un jour hockey pee-wee
petit et les compétitions de de
culturisme cimade culte j'ai commencé
l'écriture et 5 ha ok j'ai commencé en
fauteuil roulant j'ai un autre
allociné guérite où j'ai rencontré le
rencontrer
j'ai raconté au hand je regarde méchante
reine profite et je pense 2019 puis sûr
j'étais content mais j'ai plus contents
de rencontrer son staff
parce que son star parce que moi je me
suis dit si tu va se promener avec word
c'est moins sexy qui le mange que l'on
serait l'entourage pis si j'ai parlé
avec le staff
oui j'ai fait culturel
j'ai commencé à faire du pot fitness
avec des amies âgées fischer
c'est impressionnant en sacrément
vraiment que tu as tu vu la vidéo il ya
trois jours
où est ce qui est assez d'affaires en
jardin backflip j choi philippe eco est
mon gars tout tout le monde qui font du
pôle je lui donne du coup respect c'est
une telle vente ici j'y passe une heure
a essayé de faire un clip je sens le
fauteuil après je me suis dit est-ce que
je peux le faire est là parce que hors
course
je préfère être la faute et puis le
fauteuil il pèse combien parce que dans
tout ce que tu fais quand tu le fait que
le fauteuil quand même lourde puisque en
traîneau 12 qui fait qu'à chaque chose
que tu fais quand tu le fait que le
fauteuil je voyais faire des barres
parallèles voilà juste d'aider genre de
système push up sur les barres
parallèles avec ton fauteuil tu rajoutes
12 livres points de plus considérables
ces dix ports disproportionnée parce que
genre le poids de mon nom mon avant
qu'ilan bah c'est pas pareil j'essaie de
toujours équilibré le fauteuil mais
enfin à force à l'effort si randy une
extension de mon fils mais là quand tu
l'enlèves mettons situe vraiment plus
facile de faire tous ces mouvements mais
j'irai que je suis rendu à un point où
ça me dérange plus changé à un point où
c'est plus une question de ce que c'est
trop lourd c'est une question d'image
c'est vraiment rendu que je veux aussi
je suis tellement l'habitude de faire
des affaires avec mon fauteuil que c'est
plus rien en tout cas point mon fauteuil
la cia en plus en tout cas pour moi
c'est cela tout jeune à tous que je peux
utiliser la sénatrice situationnelle
ouais c'est ses fesses non il y avait le
flac line aussi j'ai commencé le buzz
n'est dépassé le slackline en fauteuil
roulant dire juste comment 1,47 enfant
je rêvais ce jeu mais incliné sur mon
football est prêt c'est de garder un
équilibre direct dessus j'ai passé au
présent et ce moment j'essaie de potes
mois le plus gros problème c'est
d'équilibrer mon fauteuil et moi
pour pas tomber par l'a20 ouais parce
que pourquoi j'essaie de pas tomber dans
le côté mais plus vers l'avant parce que
mon petit mon poids et va l'argent ça
j'essaie de me balancer cela lancés pour
vrai j'ai fait ça va faire cinq secondes
sans que personne ne touche avec mon
fauteuil
c'est un seul acte d'un c'est fou c'est
plus que moi je n'ai pas de face la cntg
et confirme que genre j'ai capoté
puis cet été on vise le second a ouai
ouai c'est une question d'équilibré
c'est fou c'est que c'est vraiment une
question d'équilibré que son pays
pourrait le stocker sur les jambes
c'est quand même plus facile parce que
vous êtes habités de s'inviter des
jambes on se sait pas comment l'exprimer
c'est plus facile puisque sebo voir du
théâtre c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
voit souvent ce cas tu vois du monde qui
font de ce à quoi je vais jean bart
des fois ils font le matin slackline par
dessus un ravin complet c'était cette
descente s'est jamais descendre
slackline peu sont au milieu de rien
voyons comme si jamais dormi sont
accrochés le mais ils sont le plus fort
il le ça swingue parce que c'est ça
ouais c'était ya vraiment beaucoup de
jeunes ça soit une plaie et fondeur des
backflips comme s'ils étaient sur une
trampoline un jet à cause que j'ai
commencé par de sacrés j'ai rencontré
par le monde 2 qui fera quoi puis le
monde à cali fourmi pourraient mettre
j'arrive pas à le trouver
sinon ouais y'a rien que tu vois que tu
dis ça je pourrais jamais faire ça au
fond il faut quelque chose qui te trouve
cool tu sais qu'il va l'essayer mais
j'ai pas encore trouvé quelque chose qui
fait non non merci je parle j'ai moi moi
et moi j'ai une princesse impôts de
froid et j'aime pas tout ce qui tout ce
qui se passe va jpac jean paul fargue
effet la slack la nappe en fauteuil
roulant qui est une princesse
c'est rien de moins de reims sinon je te
confirme que zahia la mèche qui se
vendent ce qu'ils convainquent un chalet
puis j'ai fait comme guys champeau d'ici
jean-paul challet pour faire 10 non non
soit une prime en pétrole que tu
m'emmènes à l'auto si je marche pas
comme j'ai une littérale et vidéo - d'or
puis après 300 [ __ ] je regrette comme
je mens
comme je suis entraîné d'or à m'aider
dans mon anecdote je me suis entraîné
dur cet été cet hiver trois fois ces
trois fois que je regrette même si je me
suis déjà rassuré et touche cac dont il
ya trois fois dans la vie où j'ai
regretté de m'entraîner
c'était cette fois là mais tout ça pour
dire comme moi je suis une princesse
quand ça vient au froid py.g que j'écope
j'ai vu une vidéo d'un lieu qui fait un
bac triple saut en patins sur la glace
puis je me suis dit cela
incroyable comment je peux français
attendent en photo non non non non mais
c'est quelqu'un et quelqu'un qui patine
normale et un bip bip qui patine puis il
faut enfin vaincu je pense puis c'est un
québécois s'est il agi blade puis ce
gala incroyable j'ai vu ça j'ai fait
avoir je veux commencer à faire du pet
je vais commencer à faire du patin avec
ma chaise alors j'ai contacté le
compagnie la compagnie le fauteuil
roulant c'est moche il proposait champ d
abbas alors que c'est moi qui envoie il
m'envoie les fauteuils et quand tu dis
je les renvoie mais j'explique comment
qu'après il m'envoie les fauteuils plus
turley plus plus fort qu après les
records on a une belle relation puis
j'ai contacté j'ai dit qu'on fait un
fauteuil sur glace pour l'hiver prochain
parce que c'est clair que je veux faire
du patin en fauteuil roulant c'est clair
que c'est quelque chose que je ferai
puis j'ai comme j comme j'ai plein de
dessins de moi avec un fauteuil comment
je préfère pour intégrer les parents et
tous puis si ça fonctionne mon gars
enfin je vous invite vous dit on pas ici
sur glace soit mais c'est pas ça que je
moi je en fauteuil roulant je vois vrai
fauteuil pour que guy tous ok parce que
parce que les autres c'est quand même si
c'est comme une planche avec tout ça
tout ça
ainsi que je trouve cela je vous
renverrai forte que je veux que si tomi
en fauteuil roulant qui à la mise au
repos c'est un vrai forte pour lui pour
que ses parents lui pose quelques
combats moi je vois je commençais à
faire du wiltshire nice ceux-là je vive
ont contacté mon temps il ya peu de
sport que je fais ça pour pas être
adapté ses camardes comprennent adapter
le temps d'une seule traite une seule
fois où j'ai côtoyé savent même pas si
loin d'ici envers dans une nouvelle
étape qui partent en voyage jusqu'au
bout et lagat stationnement de place
parce que sinon un concept car ft boy
parce que sans prince prend les tiges
pour que tes deux roues pas que des bacs
de la chaise pitt c'est sûr ça serait
c'est sûr ça se sent ça serait puis on
peut à ce titre tombe un peu juste
au plus fort du monde à côté des dessus
était dessus un bon argent si jamais
jamais pris je sais que chez danger mais
bon nageur
comparé à vous deux c'était pas mon
sport je flat charest je sors bien
crypte jusqu'à va de son régime soient
aussi car les enjeux
mais la force et le fait que mon hôte et
rauno comme les gens me lève puis des
fois je peux mais à part ça je caresse
hockey enfin si je sens que je non
j'essaie de toujours trouver un sport
qui a pas été adapté ou qui a été adapté
puis quand on n'en parle pas assez
si j'en amis ceinture noire au karaté
pays dans photo na waie aux apprenants
du losc usant d'une opi le gars d'ath
jennad ami qui a pas de jambes qui fait
qui fait du ski fait dire cela c'est
l'autre ouais parce que c'est quoi le
qui se passe la même chose parce que
david obey si la lutte ce qu'il fait si
comme son accord bah ouais y'a pas de
jambes puis face à six jeunes au tamis
qu'il n'y a pas de jambes puis il
fallait 1 5 qui marche i j'essaie de
toujours trouver qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour montrer que tout sport tout
prix est ce que les fédérations des
sports
est ce qu'il y aura un bon réseau
mettons pour des compétitions de ce
sport le camp non non pas parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de monde qu'en fin oui c'est le
double où m xx ème siècle
ceci jusque est en fauteuil roulant trn
le girly backflip depuis que lui a
commencé à part ça il ya les féras sauf
qu'en fait on pour intégrer le mont
d'arafat skate pilotes et les teams qui
héritera phare de 5,6 à qui est fait
descendre une rampe
c'est vrai c'est cool comme m'ayant
juste pas d'argent pour supporter le
tout ils ont en plus avec le kfw lyon se
fera beaucoup mais c'est après après
tout ça j'essaie d'être exposé d'aller
les voir pour une compétition pour des
cours continuent comme ça parce que je
trouve ça impressionnant c'est la salle
ça y est j'ai un ami qu'il faisait en
fauteuil roulant puis
j'ai lamic fed tient depuis dans un
fauteuil roulant
quand lié à un soulier seul top non mais
est en dessous puis il est la tienne
même un pays où tout est à cause de lui
je le pratique et cet été afin de mieux
j'ai contacté l'uqam des personnes qui
vont entendre qu'ils font du des
citadins j'agis gtq si je fais des
tidianes que je te lèves c'est ça la
prime de diam's est identique je te
lèves ils font genre quoi parce que je
serais je parle de cheerleader le fait
que jacques de deux confrères actif je
réponde
mais l'avantagé mais comme j'essaie de
toujours voir qu'est-ce que je peux
faire pour chaque fois je veux toujours
et les pousser à roulettes c'est non la
réponse est légèrement parce que
quelqu'un qui me dit tu peux pas parce
sa note trois fois deux groupes les
enfants
ouais comment tu me dis je peux pas
faire ça si vous marchez sur mes mains
pour que ce pays est ce que tu le fais
tu imagines fameux répondre les deux
mais est ce que tu fais pour toi pour te
dis je repose pouces mais limite ce ou
outils faut que je fasse de coupe pour
la méthode d'air pour d'autres qui
verrait ceux qui s'inspirent avant par
écoute je t'imagine j'ai devant les yeux
mais au début c'est pour moi puis
présentement c'est plus pour les autres
c'est parce que au début leur parcage
procès sur instagram français jamais si
je peux affirmer son plus mais je
pensais pas être touchée aujourd'hui ou
quel monde imoca et multi comme
référence ou le monde
ils m'envoient des vidéos de leurs
enfants qui font ça et tout si j'ai
l'équipe qui monte qui m'envoient des
vidéos de qui font des pauses avec leurs
fauteuils de la salle chauffe-eau cas ça
me réchauffe cela montre que quand tu
fais quelque chose les autres regardent
mais pour la ta question je fais fléau
pour les opéras shop
c'est dans je me pose toujours la
question si a pas de caméra est ce que
c'est quelque chose que je ferai
généralement c'est toujours oui mais qui
fait toujours oui c'est toujours lui
c'est le repos je peux tomber dans le
catégorie influenceurs pour je savoir la
tension je veux la tension mais pour
montrer que tous étaient capables chaud
c'est le plus important
mon message mon instagram est
littéralement créé pour que quelqu'un
bettex vous dit j'ai beaucoup de
confiance j'aurais pas beaucoup
d'incidents bezos de beauce passer
autrement montrer grâce à toi ça fait
trois mois que je vous dise où ça fait
trois mois que je fais si ou ça fait
trois mois que je fais ça c'est joli
drop que j'existe ans montre sur les
réseaux sur les réseaux sociaux mais
j'espère j'ai l'impression que ces
messages le il transcende vraiment les
personnes en fauteuil ou les
personnalités handicap
je pense que c'est un message qui est
vraiment universel ouais ouais ouais
c'est moi moi
on en parle des fois souvent ensemble
puis des fois dans le podcast de comment
c'est important de suivre des gens qui
t'amène un impact positif dans ta vie tu
puisses est propre à chacun qui est ce
qui amène un impact positif dans leur
ville mais moi mettons ce genre de
motivation là c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui quand je me réveille le matin
il me donne kick de plus tu parce que
parce que j'ai comme l'impression qu'on
est dans même gagne c'est moi si cette
impression là de voir que d'autres
mondes qui qui aspire un peu au même
genre de graines de vie on est quand
même bateau juste d'en déplacer sa exact
comme de se dépasser puis d'api
d'attaquer une nouvelle femme de vouloir
s'améliorer que ce soit physiquement
mais par le physique mentalement
puis j'ai l'impression que des fois puis
avec les réseaux sociaux surtout des
fois on a l'impression que l'on doit se
retrouver à mener dans un espèce de
services yeux ou est ce qu'on y est on a
comme perdu un peu le contrôle de qui
ont suivi de pourquoi on les suit et
puis je pense que de refaire le centre
de transfert de ménage de temps assez
bon vraiment gênant d'avoir comparé
contre cette personne là est-ce que cela
m'apporte puis toi tu es définitivement
dans les comptes que ces crimes
ok non sam moi j'ai l'impression qu'on
est en même bateau qu'on va de l'avant
il ya des mots qui dit que j'aidais
courage parce que je monte ma comment es
tu as mezine que ils sont saisis sont
inférieurs des fois je pourrai jamais
contrôlé comme tout ça exerce et cela
parce qu'ils m'en voyez ça j écoute
en fait on oublie moi ça me dérange pas
de come-back est fini tout j'aime j'aime
le fait que quelque chose de positif
ça peut être pour une fois ça a sûrement
pas besoin de toujours entouré de
possibles si c'est trop envahissante et
ça c'est pas mal ou quoi que ce soit
pour x ou y
en fait nous comme pourrait un jour ton
personnel je crois pas personnel il fut
un temps où j'ai perdu ce com
mille abonnés one shot parce que je sais
pas ce sens le sens parfaitement
c'est au début je fous le menteur quand
j'ai commencé à voir au levant comme ça
j'ai voulu j'ai voulu faire plus pour
les abonnés est tout à fait la ligne que
j'ai un projet 12.1 millions abonnés ou
juste trois six et trois personnes qui
sont motivés j'ai fait ma job en tant
qu'effort ça si toi tu fais ce que tu
aimes moins élevé pour trop pour un
million de personnes
tu es dans le fond en attendant dans ta
vie ça change pas grand chose comme je
dis est ce que je ferai quand je fais
quelque chose je ferais tu si je serai
film et je le fais comme un saut ça
change pas c'est juste acton que je mets
ce réseau après quand je pense qu'on est
trop facturés 10 heures treated hier à
la fois je peux pas dire quelles parades
ou maîtriser à la fois que mon saut qui
sont trop sur les réseaux sociaux sont
trop impacter ses réseaux sociaux puis
il se laisse aller c'est je vais mais
les réseaux sociaux peuvent tellement
bon pour toi si tu lis tous de bons amis
mais oui c'est pour ça que moi ça moi ça
mange tout ce qui se passe sur mon
téléphone
c'est tout ce que je veux qu'ils se
passer mon téléphone il ya quelque chose
que j'ai un peu j'en ai c'est que c'est
sale affaire c'est ce qu'ont qu'on doit
réaliser qu'on doit se forcer le
réaliser c'est qu'on a le contrôle sur
tout tu disais qu'ils restituent des
parce que c'était lourd de voir tout
plein la forme négative au début du
black eyed peas pourrais je te comprends
c'était lourd sur moi aussi j'ai comme
déconnecté il fut pendant pendant les
manifestations en juillet deux semaines
j'ai porté mon instagram
puis je vous senti bien parce que oui
c'est mon combo mais des fois c'est
lourd
sortie choisi choisis tes combats n'a
pas besoin de moi ce que je demande
enfin la journée fait le ménage à chaque
homme chaque douche mais peu de ménage
elle ménage statistiques révèlent la
merde ton téléphone peut
fait le ménage je serai un message c'est
comme tu dis il ya des gens pour qui
peut-être y voir des trucs puis à ce
moment-là ça leur folle rien que tu veux
faire moon comme ph je veux tout à fait
ça me motive c'est peut-être bien mais
je me vois du monde qui se dépassent
banque centrale ça motive beaucoup de
femmes aussi métiers différents messages
pour te faire une personne est exagérée
comme s'il ya du monde qui voit montréal
en fauteuil roulant puis la seule chose
qui sort en tête et comptent ils faire
pour sa part 16 puis du mans qui font un
mass effect c'est non c'est facile parce
qu'il ya ce qui plaque d tuer dit non
non non non mais qu est qu est rendue
quand tu vois si tu vois le regrette a
fauté sur les bords des huissiers sont
une manne compatriote easy forme ce qui
plaît de 6 watts et après réplique soit
qu'il ya quelque chose il ya quelque
chose avec toi puisse a attaqué par la
vidéo un ou deux places mais si
quelqu'un qui était de 23 marques ou où
on a dit fanny mais qui mise
complètement mais ne sait même pas il
faut ni comme quoi tu penses avec moi
base moi je m'en fous je vais dire va
cette fois on examine the stars
jj est rude à man des x men et à faire
aujourd'hui ça faisait si mal
ces réseaux sociaux ce pas parce que
t'as pas le droit de dire quelque chose
qu'il faut que je croise un terme à tous
les comptes qui me font ça soyons 0
photos ou ses déchets car c'est
quelqu'un qui me for law qui décède et
charlie leconte journée proposera tout
le monde va trouver quelque chose j'ai
du monde en fauteuil roulant qui qui
sont méritent eux aussi savaient pas ce
qu'il dit parce qu'ils disent que je
fais c'est quoi ben non explique me
concernant ses enfants dit que j'ai
appris ça restera bas aussi il ya deux
ans que cas il ya quelqu'un en photo les
bipèdes apparemment ils utilisent des
gares fauteuil roulant pour se sentir
bien à eux parce qu'ils voient ce qu'ils
font genre à la pauvre mais au moins
j'ai ça je nourris le fait que je
nourris votre égo en montre accès
handicapés soya du monde en fauteuil
roulant qui me dit à leicester pas
kingston prochain entre shampoing pas
prêt je demande aux très riches au point
par m e 10 voyez chez nos blocs sur moi
moi enfin la journée qui a toujours
quelqu'un qui va être chaud quelques va
pas ennemi qu'est ce que je fais j'ai
toujours les étages comme vous tout le
monde ne faut pas laisser soirée parité
mais tu as l'impression que les autres
c'est de dire bâti tu montres comme
comme on a parlé plus tôt n'ont pas de
casque etc dans le fond autant être en
chaise roulante peut tout faire quand
c'est facile piqué la vie est belle
comme ce puits moi quand je regarde ton
stoxx pour ce que je perçois c'est pour
se hisser plus quelqu'un et malgré les
limitations faut faire faut faire de
notre mieux qu'il faut se passer quand
même
j'avoue c'est pas de dire que quelques
que c'est facile puis on devrait porter
ce genre devraient continuer de se
battre pour l'accessibilité des
personnes appréhendées continuer tout en
montrant qu'ils sont pas parce que ta
chaise roulante qui était nécessairement
et misérable ta vie et j'avoue que
quatre gammes à vidéo je reposte dit
waouh est tellement bon pour le golf
hôtel
je veux te dire soyez ferme à cool je
vais voter je me dis joueront pas proche
de moi passer farce qu'est ce qu'on a
fait
la faute est juste comme nuances avec
avec ma vidéo ouais tu disais avant
qu'on commence à tourner et puis je
voulais que tu voulais qu'on en parle
avec toi maintenant de que tu sentais
que tu sentais pas nécessairement
représenté dans culture dans la société
québécoise
puis que tu aspires est à prendre plus
place dans l'immédiat pour que des gens
comme toi qui se sentent pas représentés
par la société québécoise
ce centre c'est à quel niveau est ce que
tu sens que les pour représenter ce que
c'est au niveau du feq ténors que sont
au niveau du fait que tu aies handicapés
c'est un mélange des deux que je pense
c'est les deux cd d'ensemble parce que
vos repas le fait que les chauffe-eau
théo là je militais que voudrait voir
plus pour ça mais ça change pas le fait
que chinois ouais sauf si je suis je ne
me vois pas dans la communauté qui a
vécu et je me sens pas que ma communauté
québécoise parce que non seulement il
n'y a pas beaucoup de noirs dans tous
les réseaux dans les mains ce crime
il y en a plus en plus parce qu'on n'en
a pas on n'a pas un mais ya pas de
guerre faut-il pas un handicap vraiment
puis c'est un honneur parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui fait qu'elle est
handicapée vers 16 il ya dirigé les amis
à montréal qui aimeraient cet acteur ben
ils seront toujours dire non non non je
la mi temps et écoute sont deux mecs
j'ai un ami qui est en fauteuil roulant
kiki boulet fiscal 2010 non parce que on
voit les vidéos de on va aller on va
laisser répit à son propre à faire ça à
cette activité à cette activité de puis
on sait y j mee a même envoyé sa
créature il est il s'est inscrit bien
bonne nouvelle si au plus haut niveau
qui serait inscrit à chaque année et
émettons compris cet exemple le il ya eu
une personne trans il depuis les plis de
plus en plus de personnes
des couleurs j'ai l'impression que c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être un step je
suis passé à cette année mais à
maintenir volvo c'est vrai oui non non
moi je la ferai ça même raison que toi
c'est quoi la savait raconter la fois
c'est à chaque fois que tout le monde se
pose c'est pourquoi à chaque fois je
réponds qu à chaque fois je réponds bah
je répond j'aime ma vie premièrement
fait que j'ai pas besoin d'entrer que
j'ai paul pop auquel tout le monde qui
vole un ballon devenu si j'agis pas
besoin de changer rien en ce moment ça
va bien mais j'aurais aussi j'ai
l'impression que ce n'est que ça me fait
tilter un peu le puits que je pars est
très possible ce n'est pas la même
raison que toi il ya quelqu'un qui a dit
quelque chose que je me suis dit ouais
mais aussi parce que la fin avec
occupation double c'est c'est en tout
honneur et tout ça a beaucoup changé à
travers les générations
puis même aujourd'hui c'est c'est
beaucoup même beaucoup mais beaucoup de
sujets pas de contrôle de moi j'ai pris
le contrôle de qui je suis 5 personnes 2
j'ai pas de contrôle de je suis un
bouffon genre 99% à 10 heures si tout
cela m'a mise en jeu tout seul en
exemple j'ai ri quand même car le
congrès puis je sens comme si je vous
renvoie la balle cas les contrôles comme
je suis un bon gars car des fois c'est
des fois je me ferai voter blanc
j'aurais tout cela je me vois tout seul
en toile est tard grâce à des objets à
paris puis à prendre part ou dit
encouragé par le parler de cela la
caméra pas nommé comme adamo l'a fait
mais j'y suis 5000% soeur je l'aurais
fait avant lui ça maintenant à 1000% ça
comme je sors un salut la poète qui ont
été vos journées
mais enfin combinant ses bourreaux des
médecins tu peux pas adressés la
production mais comme 85 92 % les choses
que jean faure qui prend pas le mettre à
regarder l'autre hong kong - mais ça
serait intéressant d'avoir quelqu'un a
croisé deux puis aussi la question de s
que le coc chic la majorité des coupes
sera pas authentique est ce que
quelqu'un fait craindre vraiment aimer
quelqu'un faut tellement pourquoi parce
que je trouve que je ferais que j'avais
dans un bar à dos de dating parce que ma
long mais on peut en parler parce que
c'est intéressant
toi le dating c'est quelque chose qui
est comment c'est quoi ton expérience
des temps en étant quelqu'un en fauteuil
mois qu'ils ont honte de ce que tu
connais des risques ashton parce que moi
j'ai pas de problème je serai dans
l'achat d'un débat et ou alors et je
raconte beaucoup m'ont dit c'est pas le
fauteuil qui dérange
je t'ai j'ai jugé aussi j'y prends
démarche santé avait quelqu'un sait pas
ce qui me donne moi en général mon
fauteuil je sais pas ça que je veux je
veux je vais essayer de montrer aux
autres
dijon va pas s'arrêter puis à pete par
hasard un temps fauteuil mais je pense
que c'est pour ça que l'interaction
c'est pas si pire que sera ce bien ça se
passe bien j'ai des amis qui sont plus
gênés puis quand tu es plus gêné quand
tu es plus restreint quand le réseau est
vrai avait 11 rien que voir le fauteuil
tu vois plus le fauteuil
comment est-ce que les reconversions que
la personne - si la paire situe pas déjà
elle serait intéressée à moi vu que je
tends faute et si c'est plus facile et
même pas ça c'est juste s'il ya du monde
dans huit mois il ya du bourget leur vie
en fauteuil roulant aussi oui puisque
même par rapport avec les fauteuils en
même temps il croise une fille qui est
fait de la paroisse elle va jamais le
voir comme pas parce qu'il est jeune et
on
pas ce qui est en faute et des personnes
personnes veulent personnes veulent
l'admettre c'est vrai il ya beaucoup de
bons il ya beaucoup de l'ombre comme si
je vous pose la question en ce moment
s'entretient avec les caf au tc a
maintenant la patiente est et ouest
compatible à 100 pour ça c'est vraiment
une bonne question c'est aussi une
question pour qu'il faut être honnête en
version wifi c'est correct faudrait que
ça arriverait que je laisse jouer avec
le singe faudrait que je sache si si je
vois la personne un premier temps avant
de voir l'indicatif je pense beaucoup la
question des foreuses et to be c'est la
première fois j'ai posé la question
99% et parfois dans des oui c'est comme
ça aussi qu'on leur annonce de cette
belgique
j'ai posé la question puis j'ai dit car
je m'en fous les vraies choses
il a beaucoup qui m'ont écrit paraît
grave juste podor non quand je m'en fous
ton par ailleurs dit non c'est correct
puis c'est pas le cas ça c'est pas
mauvais comme c'est très hypothétique
avant de rencontrer une personne qui
d'être offerts aux pères le lama des
fruits même pour reformuler la question
thônex est ce que est ce que c'est
est-ce que ça durait au tac ça dure et
c'est en faudrait même personne c'est
une grosse question grosse question
c'est de celà dit aussi parce que le
daring poule pour quelqu'un il faut que
c'est pourquoi je sens comme ça toujours
le toucher c'est le daily nk pro pour
quelqu'un en fauteuil roulant si on me
demande toujours pourquoi tu seras pas
écrit un fauteuil basque et donc
personne chez les personnes intéressées
une grosse question pays pauvres est
j'ai besoin d'un par ado dit justin
ouais vraiment parce que le dating pour
parce que qu'on n'en parle pas assez
c'est vrai qu'on n'en parle pas assez en
fait on en parle littéralement jamais
jamais dit ce serait un sujet souvent
intéressant on dit serait l'idéal
des podcasts dating monde connaît mais
toi mais tout ça tu aimais toute somme
soit un obstacle ou ses pattes un
obstacle pour toi maintenant comme je
dis moi on dirait que je participe je
suis partie par une tâche est une
exception autres enfants parce que
justement les 8 puis aussi je marche
aussi des fois j'ai l'air d'un gars qui
marche puis je marche un sou à trois
autres batailles mais je marche bien
c'est garder qu'un ticket du monde et 6
4 bois tu marches droit pour ouvrir
l'aéroport
je marche le plus droit un nom dans un
avion ouais je penche sur les gueux qui
marche le plus dur je pense que je vous
dis j'aime marcher aussi droit de ma vie
mon dieu comment ce l'avion ou chèque
chaque fois que tu as il est prêté sur
l'effet placebo ouais je marche
tellement droit que c'est rendu que
monsieur que vous
certes mais comme une hérésie quand je
dis que moi c'est pas un problème parce
que j'aime adresse
si j'y vis est brûlante m'ont dit oui je
pense pas que ça marchait pas ce
qu'était un fauteuil puis j'étais un peu
tout propre aveu puis à force de me re
paris quelque chose après parce que
qu'ils ont vu
c'est pas la chaise qui était beaucoup
plus que tout ben ouais on est beaucoup
plus que dronneau défaut ouais ouais on
est beaucoup plus que nos défauts mais
la question c'est est ce que tu es prêt
à regarder au-delà au monde était là ben
ouais on va voir au delà de la chaise
parce que c'est quand même c'est quand
même si quand le dire ouais parce que
c'est une question une chose qui me
revient souvent quand le monde ment pas
c'est mes amis et ma famille vont passer
à quoi ils vont penser que je suis là
parce que je veux tu es des houles par
pitié ou quoi que ce soit puis pour 3,2
par an 2 e
quand une relation si les deux parties
en deux ans
sinon c'est vraiment une grosse caisse
et j'en passe autres gars qui vont avoir
de langage hand est enclenché oui parce
que dit toi cathy majoré avec quelqu'un
c'est comme les embauches s'exclament
les homosexuels il ya pensé c'était le
rabbin pourquoi parce que je regardais
le record d'europe des potes du coin
c'est une belgique qui tient la main
d'abord frotté qualifie en faux travers
une fille en fauteuil parce que vous
êtes de gueule mais une personne en
fauteuil
je connais mon homosexualité une
personne en fauteuil roulant puis vous
prenez naturellement on vous regarde et
je vous jure j'ai dit je te dis jamais
ne pas être des amis fille puis tout le
monde nous regarde tout le monde nous
regarde
pire même du vent qui sont assez à
l'aise de me voir me dire ça fait
combien vous sentez enfants puis
maintenant je ménage plus connu ma phase
est plus connue sylvander what a quand
même réussi à trouver une fille magritte
à la faute et s'est confronté chose
qu'elle va trouver c'est quoi ça c'est
une transgression vraiment il ya encore
des stigmates à satiété par rapport à
beaucoup si man city mais la face et on
pense pas que c'est un problème c'est
pour ça que parfois vous le régler
comment qui se manifeste et stig moeller
mettant à apport des occasions comme ce
camp vingtaine d'heures tenir deux
jeunes amis en fauteuil qui bat loeb
pourrait avoir sa femme demain j'irai
oui mais comme ils mentent pas ils me
fais pas exprès pour montrer son
fauteuil roulant dans ses photos pierre
et sur la d faut parler avec la personne
pour voir la chimie pour avoir une dette
parce que poppy défaut même rendu là et
il pas plus mais enfin la journée donc
donc remettons la personne d'autre côté
cpo que le jazz et ses conséquences mais
c'est quand même kaczysnki comme quelque
chose de gros de gros ouais mais
puis c'est ça en même temps on peut
quand même comprendre que c'est pas tout
le monde qui est prêt à croire ce que
souvent il se présente le piston choc
puis la personne fait qu'ils n'ont je
peux pas pu vraiment c'est dur parce que
je ne l'aurais pas fait parce que tu
l'amanti métro pour de l'envergure parce
que tu comprends pourquoi
ouais parce qu'il sait qu'elle grossit
mais sa chaise roulante soit son profil
de la février de voir à travers
il se dit aussi quand est-ce que c'est
du quatre fiches
non je pense pas parce que un café c'est
techniquement tu veux mon développement
photo 3 2 avant pour que la personnalité
ça va bien pour que après quand tu te
rends compte fait à ce moment- un peu
mais un peu ducati c'est ce qu'affiche à
ces fois dire un peu sauf qu'en même
temps passait tellement c'était déjà mon
cousin tu penses quoi donc si situe
semaine photo d'avant at on indiqué
photographe tim des photos juste devant
au score
seul mentionne pour mentionne pas il te
raconte la fille pas fait non maman
titre ma 4 x 4 fiches
c'est vraiment compliqué parce que je
pense que ça implique cette question la
réplique on conçoit honnête envers nous
mêmes contre cosa vrai que si on tient
maintenant j'ai fait ce travail là par
rapport aux différentes couleurs de peau
tu vois je suis dit est-ce que
est ce que c est ce que je puis je peux
je pourrais être en couple avec une
personne non mais ton juste par
attirance physique toute l'équipe
puis la réponse que j'ai eues en étant
honnête envers moi même si oui sauf que
c'est une question qui est quand même
fallu que je n'ai pas hésité parce que
je me suis dit ah mais j'ai amené toutes
mes blondes étaient blanches tout le
monde que j'ai fréquentés on était resté
coi le facteur qui t'a fait visiter
pourquoi le fait la couleur de la peau
ça fait ou non n'a pas fait ça c'est
juste que ça arrivait jamais ok ok tous
cas ma vie toutes les personnes verte
j'étais attirée ya jamais une personne
noire danse dans ce bassin asiatiques
latino
rires non c'est sûr que moi évidemment
quelque chose manque quand ils sont à
québec où est-ce que j'ai grandi be with
me suis développé que j'ai développé mes
relations interpersonnelles by me et
puis ma sexualité tout ça c'était dans
un milieu ultra blanc est fixé juste ce
qui est arrivé x terra nova szohr que ça
se soit jamais passé de ses piques et
j'ai jamais forcer pour que ça arrive
parce que je vous ai forcé pour que ça
arrive ci-contre et us f1 ne peut aussi
leur grange à québec le droit de québec
de famille la belle forme
parmi les quelques mets mes fesses effet
que si je me suis posé la question
puisse amener ces sites internet en
verre envers soi même puis ça s'est tu
vois si je ne m'étais jamais posé
vraiment puis je suis fallait qu'il
fallait que je fasse l'introspection pas
mal pour essayer de voir tes parce que
généralement quand quelqu'un quand ils
pensent à quelques handicaps et tu
penses tu qu'ils y dépendants et
indépendants
ça dépend de toi quand tu penses à
quelqu'un en fauteuil roulant est ce que
ta veste mots de passe et des répondants
où ils se désistent steegmans
je pense qu'il y ait des prix
indépendant parce que dès que je
pourrais y sont incités à la personne la
travers la rencontre la personne
autrement elle aussi de penser bon il va
dépendre il vas voir tu va vouloir
dépend de moi dx direct et tout mais les
gars il ya ce moment et le taux y
conduit
il sauve en effet son épicerie tout seul
puis je pensais que la personne en tant
que tel et indépendante c'est juste
qu'ils ont encore aujourd'hui on le dit
dans tout il ya des troubles sont pas
adaptés le temps pour ces personnes le
fait que sa part une situation où est-ce
que s'adapter les passants serait 100%
indépendante mais c'est juste que la
société on n'est pas encore rendu à
pouvoir permettre notre va permettre ce
gène précis mais en fait parce que ça
change rien sur la dépendance de la
personne c'est la personne peut être
dépendante même s'il ya des endroits qui
sont pas adaptés mais je pense que c'est
plus une question de la seconde que tu
commences à la rationalité du fai baron
si c'était tout à fait dépend est tout à
fait indépendante elle même sauf que
quand tu la pose effectivement il ya
comme un il ya une hésitation
illustration d'un conte le rationalisme
devrait ancrer ça regarde les styles
c'est il faut pas oublier il ya peu tout
le monde sont comme moi mais valdes à la
magie du mot que je connais en fauteuil
ça conduit s'affaiblissent riz n'ont pas
besoin de personne par exemple par
simple même je connais un grand fauteuil
électrique de gueye bush juste sommes en
temps de guerre très très départ très
très indépendant legault si cabaye il
fait des blagues il s'amuse avec cet
homme c'est ifaci taxe by istres à gouye
diama a trouvé sa douce moitié
cisco vraiment puis j'ai pas que je peux
pas blâmer le mans se hisse au t2 et où
il ya sans faute il ya eu dans son
intégralité ici bein ouai il n'y a pas
beaucoup dit oui en fait y'a pas de
bâche comme on l'appelle est ainsi son
prix inarritu le garrec spi l'on passe
pas et tous n'y a pas de match
pij de membres est ce que c'est vraiment
le fait que visualise mans
visuellement il ya la dépendance puis à
l'heure de x yolande y puis il répond à
vos stéréotypes que le mot je porte ce
qui est petit en deux c'est vraiment
ouais c'est pas parce que tu joues la
personne que par le passé sur le
physique c'est quand même sens que celle
ci personne la seule information toutes
ces personnes ne puissent pas que c'est
correct mais je sais juste de comprendre
le cheminement la seule information tout
c'est à une limitation était apprécié et
en est à 9 206 tandis que
juste des bio j'ai des billets ajoute la
personnalité vous c'est quelque chose
que je comprends mais même à se
canaliser singer est légal trois fois
plus gros que moi
quand vous êtes pris vous allez leur
gueule landreau puis ça marche c'est
pour ça j le monde en fauteuil seront
quand même histoire quand même parce que
c'est quand je vous pose action vous
hésité puis vous aider vous et dumont
très honnête avec vous-même vous êtes
camp du monde qui vous êtes vous êtes
très owens est très vous est très
endetté le fait que vous visitez ça
démontre beaucoup ça parle beaucoup
parce que quelqu'un a besoin de tout le
monde dans le parc ou quoi que ce soit
je pose la question ils vont bien oui
oui oui
pourtant de façon ferme en fin de
journée un chic c'est non non c'est sa
séquence était jamais arrivé j'en
connais très peu épicé pour c'est pour
ça encore une fois que je reviens avec
fermeté ton ex parti ça réduirait aussi
longtemps mais s'ils discutent en plus
maintenant les camps pas saisi puis
opère dans un beau deux textes et moins
- vous dites je pense que je trouvais
bien que c'est sûr que c'est sûr que
c'est une introspection il va se faire
3par dans le temps le dira juste à y
réfléchir et penser je m'étais jamais
posé la question pour qui j'avais j
avais jamais été confrontée mettons à
cette question est ce que tu as déjà vu
quelqu'un fotolog pas dit elle et qui
m'aiment pas qu'il est belle ou chat
tirer outre paris berne en suisse
je pense à une personne en particulier
keserwan delphine non moi tu montres
après la partie
car détriment bmc nice où le maire
depuis campagne j'avais pour moi qui a
tombé sur le dos avec ma chaise puis
j'en vois la photo qui fait encore mieux
quand j'envoie libyen a presque tout le
monde dit yo pour rien au début de la
pandémie
quand j'ai envoyé 310 avant de joie
parce que je peux juste pour tout le
monde l'attend dimanche
et puis des fois ils envoyaient des
idées des autres est aussi 2 mai soit 5
mai ses a amené je pense qu'en avril
j'envoyais à tout et j'écrivais aux
hôpitaux à québec montréal tout depuis
tout le monde qui travaille à l'hôpital
j'ai envoyé dit merci pour tout ce que
tu fais pas de taoussa dumont à des
travailleurs essentielles sont
essentielles comme son clip il est bon
et merci pour ce que tu fais là c'est
carrément non les attraits pas merci où
ils bloquent pif études
dû remplacer des rebonds corps ne
présente qu un jour il ya du monde qui
m'envoient des ignifuges à tous si je
suis un peu toujours mais je trouve ça
important de c'est pas moi moi je trouve
ça important d'envoyer dit un mot des
fois quand je vois me mener vas-y que
comme égorger du corps c'est quoi chic
libérer des oméga-6 comme égaux premier
cas du genre site internet que tu peux
rencontrer du monde
après trois caps genre entre allemands
le grand complet mais j'écris québec
parce que c'est comme un peu
chatroulette site site chatroulette mais
plus contrôler et civilisé gay qui se
masturbe moi non mais ces ouvriers le
coma les griffons il ya une caméra je
dois m'asseoir et afat et l'ouest
j'écris québec pis si je peux paraître
n'importe qui au québec puis moi je
prends le plaisir de regarder le monde
les yeux puis je fais toi là tu
comprends malade est incroyable bonne
journée
c'est tout six toiles à l'incroyable pas
français que jobs jusqu'à samedi 12
septembre
je m'ennuie des fois je pense d'eux a
emmené jeu rien que je fais tout cas
d'un stack et les livres sont à tête pim
fond je pense que oui puis on faire en
forme on met quatre cinq livres sur la
tête puis que cha mon gars c'est ce que
ja devant kim skiff
mais le mans qui reste puisqu'en s'amuse
cinq ans je pense que je gagne comme
2000 personnes juste en face à simone
d'aider les gens qui sont seules à ces
temps de pandémie non jusqu'à parler de
mon ensemble font chaque dimanche c'est
incroyable
si en plus c'est le fun parce que tu
peux choisir au des fois j'écris france
bonjour
bonjour comment allez vous quoi le
personnage d'armes où se rencontre on a
tellement ri ensemble quand je fais un
cas là bas est extradé mais non mais
j'ai cette bonne ville puisque je peux
puis je m'amusais ben je veux qu'on
parle un peu avant de laisser aller de
la semaine altergo on ne peut pas tout
est fini mais je veux quand même qu'on a
à part la semaine intergros parce que
c'est
c'est une activité que tu te faisais tu
fais depuis que tout petit dans le fond
le jeu par ses passes tout petit tout
petit en quoi ça consiste exactement
ben en fait c'est un événement qui
rassemble toutes les écoles qui ont des
personnages sur son handicap ou quoi que
ce soit à faire du sport cia 10 cd
olympiades c'est vraiment cool
il ya des courses en fauteuil l'écossé
avec démarche est des courses quoi que
ce soit il ya lancer du poids si c'est
vraiment tout ce qui critique qui a dû
passer en fauteuil roulant une journée
il ya du boccia le budget c'est comme ça
non donc c'est quand il a mis la tête
non vous êtes fait déjà avec l'écotaxe
et pour faire simple on écoute mais
surprise c'est le début après bonjour je
l'avais vous dit c'est quand même un peu
triste quand la pétanque mais avec le
monde en fauteuil roulant qui utilisent
soit des tuyaux pour mettre à bâle puis
pourrait si stratégiquement tuyaux puis
il demande à la personne qui peut
contrôler un petit peu à gauche ou à
droite c'est surtout de mort en faute
électrique en pis savoie côté alain
paralympiques
on a comme quatre personnes au québec
sont extrêmement il domine le sport
mondialement quelqu'un bct gp temps
n'est pas aux chochottes biwetz et
bocchèse pourrait c'est un beau sport
s'impose pas pittsburgh il ya de la
course d course en fauteuil roulant est
cependant je pense y deux semaines
pendant ces deux semaines
il ya des activités aussi pour montrer
que oui tendance n'est ce pas grave on
est là pour t'aider on est là pour sarko
âgées ont créé une communauté que j'ai
commencé depuis général ont pigé cancer
ambassador ça fait 2 3 1 et est
ambassadeur j'ai réalisé
env j'ai rasé que pascal est en baisse
alors je vois différemment des autres
adamant ch et la couette ouais c'est
cool j'ai gagné deux médailles versus de
jeu delà des médailles aux jeunes qui je
vois la réaction qui font qu'il ya des
jeunes qui ont tombé dernière place mais
le fait qu'ils y ont tout donné
si j'ai regardé que jobs puisqu'on merci
merci ils sont contents avec le cnv un
marché comme on dit c'était dernière
dernière derrière dallas puis je roulais
à côté des jeux comme moins d'être
couvre les coûts puis le fait que boyet
est la petite dernière voyage us
le gars côté les dépenses et seraient
donc moins de vingt-six quoi ça parle
bush contre l'oubli j'oubliais chercher
l'europe en bazar
puis on s'est rendu compte ce court
c'est pour pôle derbi
regardez comme a dit jeter les sidaïques
mais quand c'est un mot valorisant de
voir du mont perdu pas malgré le
handicap marie malheureusement dans la
pandémie de malheureusement d'une
pandémie mais il ya trois ans j'aurais
invités à venir voir serais gré de for
pi à chaque fois j'ai vu quelqu'un
allait le y réalise que quoi la
compétition ça peut s'attendre à ça pas
de couleurs sont pâles imitations juste
c'est beau à voir
vraiment c'est vraiment comme il ya une
raison pourquoi ça fait 14 ans que tu as
raison pourquoi ça fait quinze ans que
j'y vais religieuse mais à chaque année
parce que c'est important
c'est beau avoir peace a fait le monde
qui ont participé aujourd'hui ils voient
aller tu vois qu'ils quittent parfois
avec une confiance en eux ils font leur
truc ça paraît que ça là ça nous a aidés
à sortir de la carapace nirvana c'est
vrai si si si c'est vrai pour les gens
avec un handicap c'est vrai en fait pas
n'importe quelle personne phalangiste de
bouger de faire du sport faire quelque
chose dépassé
c'est sa main tellement positif c'est
pile but si je pense je pense je
découpais excuse mais je pense que la
raison pourquoi c'est aussi ça réussit
au taz parce que la fille qui est dans
sa course normale bach qui après
handicap pendant deux semaines
il ya du monde qui l'a ressemble pied du
monde qui font qu est ce qu a fait puis
elle se fait des amis
pis ça crée une communauté je pense
c'est vraiment ça qui démontre waouh
c'est pas juste parce que si moi je fais
quelque chose
aujourd'hui mon favori c'est parce que
vous dit tout mais je bosse qui a dopé
son quart à fort worth pensez vraiment
le fait que le fait qu'on a une
communauté bas jusqu'à présent dans une
communauté au québec de par sa faute et
olaru parfois limitations physiques puis
quand ils font des trucs incroyables
pourrais-je
c'est un honneur de faire partie de ça
ça doit être pour un jeune qui prend un
c'est soit pour un jeune qui sans succès
marginaliser la de retrouver du monde
qui sont qui sont comme toi seul au tate
sur la tête tellement soulagée tellement
gratifiant mais je me rappelles tu es
dans dés ce genre d'activité le loup est
ce que tu mets ton juste les jeux du
québec mettant jude québec parce que là
tu étais juste tout le monde ensemble
ces crises et c'est le fun puis avait il
y avait appelé ses vastes et les
olympiques spéciaux qui est elle avec
avec oui je pense
mais peut-être que ça s'appelle puis
comme ça je pense que je pense que
maintenant c'est sûr maintenant je pense
qu'il y allait y appelait son hormis nos
nous on était les normes in hope il y
avait celle aussi réalisé à l'époque
mais en même temps que je ne sais pas je
me rappelle plus je sais pas quand on
s'appelle maintenant mais d'entendre ce
test est comme ça s'appelait sur des
gens avec un handicap mental parce
qu'ils étaient dans l'équipe aussi été
pour eux ça changeait tout
s'il faut changer tout au tout les
samoussas c'est moi c'était comment les
jeux du québec c'est comme c'est que
c'est le fun c'est une expérience mais
pour eux c'était juste qu'un mec ça
change du bio qui change la vie
je vous rappelle les premiers jeux du
québec que j'ai fait juste
en plus d'un gros jeu des caves moi je
voyais très gore faux pas je regarde
non moi je capote et que je tirais
lebreux mon coach du genre regard vous
dis c'est légal si je vous raconte tout
la ligue 1 paul je comprends mes mains
pourquoi acheter d'ici un abri parce que
je vois enfin du monde qui me ressemble
c'est ce soit un basket puis on dit les
choses que j'agissais cash et j'en sais
c'est qu'on joue puis le fait que son
fauteuil par est de jouer ta voix
doucement jaillissait ça pour la
première fois je tombe à tort tout le
monde personne à personne à rennes c'est
tout qui continue c'est la stratégie on
l'a fait tomber
bon dans la vente âge moi le matin tu y
es tu tombé je vois que nuire à mon
équipe je me remontent jusqu'au jour
puis c'est compétitif
t et depuis ce temps là quand le quand
je jouais avec du monde debout je fais
non elle n'a pas de jouet continue chez
laisser une chance il prend pas comme
c'est ça que j'aime le fait que tu me
prends pas pour nos frères gille plus
bas non juste qu'avec c'était par
rapport au ban par rapport si j'ai fait
une faute si j'ai fait une erreur de
pénaliser sa a perdu mon équipe alors je
valais que je pousse fallait que je
monte et pour 45 pour 40 minutes j'étais
égal à tout le monde pour 40 minutes y'a
pas d'anti cap pour 40 minutes
c'était vraiment moi que moi et mon
équipe compte notre équipe ça pour ça
c'était fou et jusqu'à des pauvres hères
gros charente abou jamra maison c'est
formateur pourront elles mènent le monde
italie en tant que joueur coach
assistant
moi aussi j'ai fait ces deux avions
j'arrête pas de revenir puis même des
mêmes d'handisport raconter les autres
sports par lui à un pic à la cafétéria
de voir qu'il ya d'autres sports que le
basket je pense à man et blues dans ma
tête tout le monde et sa marge au basket
puis leur attrait à réaliser qui n osent
pas la gymnastique ça existe ça ça
existe ça existe non c'est juste que
c'est vraiment important vraiment était
allée aux jeux du canada aussi soyons
justes quart d'heure en 2019
je pensais même réaction si moi aussi
les réactions
un préfet on est allé au ping pong qui
m'ont à taiping pas cool le gars qui
représentait le québec
magog il faisait comme puis l'a frappé
en cours ça que j'ai mon gars et quand
nous en manière d'un registre allons
capitaine j'ai chaud juste à y penser
ouais c'est vraiment des expériences
celle observée poussé pour les gentils
et mettons c'est d'aller aux jeux du
québec en tant que personnes sans
handicap d'été de côtoyer parce que tu y
vas pas des fois on non on se côtoie
moins d'être tout une même équipe
ensemble de tout et avoir cet esprit
d'équipé avec certaines personnes qui
ont des handicaps d'autres non mais
c'est comme ces bottines doute à
converger aussi s'il y en avait dans
notre équipe tdd déjà et il y avait des
handicaps intellectuels mais dont je
pense à philippe le tiki tv des
handicaps physiques ou 6 puis j'avais
mon coach et j'écoute chez moi les
jeunes pij à une année j'avais coacher
l'équipe de deux jeunes gens un
handicapé physique l'expérience humaine
ce pas super super belle mais tim et on
philippe la fierté mettons qu'il y avait
de faire partie de l'équipe
beauxis même si lille est si comme i
mank de l'équipe du rouge et or la plus
belle chose c'est pis tant pour pour
tout pour lui qui prend vraiment dans sa
vie à bitumer d'être marginalisée en
tant que personnes qui ont un handicap
intellectuel fait peut-être partie de
l'équipe c'est tellement de syrte est
tellement beau pizzo delevoye aussi ça
nous fait grandir c'est comme ça fait
grandir tout le monde parce que pour toi
si j'aurai une compression banal de la
bla mais quand je réalise lui il pétrit
peut-être il y avait au pire qu'un clip
qui se produit juste le voir
qu'est ce qui se passe après 62 n'avait
pas ce que lui comme peut-être que les
gars moi c'est que ces bovins japon
je m'appelle je pense une idée parfois
j'allais au juste québec moi c'est come
back sixième fois je prends moi ça
chaque deux mois c'est comme dans ma
4ème 5ème et 6ème fois puis jockey est
ce que les jeunes on va bien qu'étudiant
plus qu'aux autres et manger
je réalise puis en voyant son camp waouh
ça s'apprend à foix il y aura t-il tout
pitt et son texte est sur facebook où
dit il nous reste raison il nous reste
et je sais que c'est possible si elle
était rendue c'est quand tu es grandeur
modalités je sais qu'il ya des gens qui
trouvent qu'ils voient comme un modèle
est ce que toi quand tu es jeune tu en
avais dessus des modèles ou ce qu'ils
ont et l etat il tend à répondre mais je
les rapports lazy legz c'est le gars qui
fait a dit danse avec ces békés des noms
qui met en garde il ya québécois qui
danse avec bic et puis il ya créé une
troupe de danse avec un handicap
ils vont y voir au tour du monde puis ça
fait ça ça fait des progrès c'est beau à
voir
je connais pas je m'arrête pas slogan
parker mais vous vous tapez ça les
hyleks ccc voir le griffer des des wind
millau avec avec ses jambes qui frappe
partout ça sert d'abord comme rapport
lui plus ou moins non c'est pour ça je
me dis j'ai fait un post récemment à 10
ans on aura en plus de représentations
en fauteuil roulant quand je pense à un
super héros en photographie pour ça qui
est légèrement trop saïx mais je peux me
paraît présenté par gulf shores qui il
bouge dans un billet vert à 1 puis la ja
devant chrono mais il y en a un autre
convoi tentant de temps en temps si si
qui apparemment il ya quelqu'un qui
s'est fait mal à travers l'écran est
grand temps en fauteuil roulant qui mais
je ne vous mens je parle de quelqu'un
qui qu'en fauteuil roulant d'elle dès le
départ il existe comme on a besoin
d'autres représentations
moi je vois spider man quel 8 en
fauteuil roulant après il y en a réuni
qui a écrasé puis le fait qu'il allait
écraser sahara comme transformer sa
chaise en tant que bien sonné
j selon lui il serait fou malade victime
puis au nom de fois j'ai croisé vous
arrivez en espérant que j'allais pouvoir
c'est pour ça je me dis à force de moi
que je fais quelque chose à force que
l'autre personne fait des choses on voit
on voit passer pour que le mont font ça
serait cool de faire quelque chose avec
eux j'ai lu un article chamailleurs qui
parlait de deux représentations de
différents handicaps à hollywood mais
tant pis ça disait qu'il n'avait plus en
plus tôt n'essayez le film je pense
qu'on a tenté par les deux méthodes je
n'ai parlé ici c'est un film qui traite
de la de la surdité dans le folklore
c'est tout dit avec mais n'a pas fait le
poids de naissance et une liste des
juges benoit et la cdg côté jeunes parce
que moi mais non mais c'est ce type il a
cité en exemple utilisée pour commencer
à avoir de plus en plus des films qui
traitent de santé mais ça reste ça sera
pire c'est quand même dire qu'on
commence à avoir plus en plus au nord où
plusieurs syndicats de d'âge était un
facteur principal qui sont pas de karaté
et tout recommence
sinon mais c'est vrai mais si juste
juste devant jouer attaquer jouer
attaquer québec juste district pendant
beau clip 44 94
si je voulais martina il pourrait pas
gérer en défense mais non congrès
t'imagines s'il y avait quelqu'un en
fauteuil roulant ça serait pas quelqu'un
en fauteuil roulant pour ouvrir ce
serait quelqu'un qui serait dit mais moi
moi j'aurais oublié et woody luc hallade
cap sa tatie de weck quelque chose ou
même un rocky le gars y'a pas photo
moulin maintenant j'ai pas il ya un film
qui vous ils veulent faire un film puis
j'arrive aux auditions qui s'attendait
pas que le grand photographe puis voir
ma performance du fonds on veut quand
même
quelque chose si je peux être acteur
sinon si on ne daigne quelqu'un si vous
avez besoin de quelqu un quelque chose
je trouve que on n'a pas de on n'a pas
assez de représentant au québec comme
miami en fauteuil roulant on sent qu'on
se parle entre nous on trouve ça normal
qu'ils pensent pas nous mais c'est pas
correct mais je pense que tu sais c'est
le problème de représentativité de
toutes les différences de toutes les
différences entre les différents stades
c'est juste qu'il faut être conscient
qu'il ya plus que le sexe qui est plus
qu est la couleur de peau que plus que
les handicaps qui plus que tout soit et
tout ceci toutes les différences décidé
de représenter mieux la société en
général c'est qu'on parle de diversité
karam et on oublie moi qui imaginent
vous me connaissez pas quand vous avez
parlé de divertir diversité diversité
diversité du verteillacois diversité
diversité non pas d'un berger diversité
qui continuent à inciter ont diverti
diversité diversité diversité
sauf quand on parle de diversité
on pense pas au goût compense pas un
handicap
on pensait on pense aussi à la soca
--chargée pyj et en proposant quelques
infos tél
tous mes enfants encore une affaire de
plus on parle souvent parler sexualité
souvent parle de technicité souvent on
parle de 2
de xy m'envoyant parler de guerre
photographe parce qu'on assume le grand
fauteuil il faut pas être acteur mais
c'est pas vrai j'ai la main au fond de
moi qui modèle mais pour une modeste
fallait qui chialent brillamment
longtemps enfin qui se paye et c'est un
beau bonhomme mes fans et qui change
vraiment vraiment vraiment longtemps de
l'aïd el idha des populations de co2
cause la répudiation de de déodorant
puis même là il ya encore la misère
d'avoir des guides parce que tout le
monde assume qu'il faut pas le faire
puis ils vont de jeu pense que je serais
capable de faire mais toute la publicité
le greta c'est en fait le guide assis
puis la camry ou mal voyantes au jeu car
de faire ça sans même y penser
pis si tu me dis à tes trop à gauche ben
cousins tchèques
c'est pour ça que je trouve que on se
trouve trop d' excuses
georges l amitié trahie au mcdo pas ce
que j'appelle un trip pillon tout dedans
oui mais tous cas les besoins c'était un
petit peu place à la caisse c'est tout
puis alors plus fort ben l'oeil à
conserver lyon trouvé d'autres excuses
mais non mais non je comprends moi aussi
je comprends pistes un problème juste
avant une fois de laisser définitivement
puis le monde ont tendance à dire un
état parfois piller une diversité à la
fois en même temps que son mari les
project 1
parce que si tu me dis je paye dans un
film avec mylène st-sauveur au coudray
je faisais all-in 520 et sa part fardeau
sur les salaires
c'est quand même fou ça quand même
relativement beaucoup de chance qu'avec
quelqu'un à l'auditoire sans fil qui la
connaissent pas ces trois salons
heureusement je suis à tanger vimy ça
amène on met tout ça pour dire si je
porte c'est maman est venue ici au
québec
voilà ce que haïti un peu des
opportunités que quelqu'un que voulaient
au québec
je finissais au canada parce que je
trouve que ce serait bon pour moi et mon
enfant est né ici et aider la jeunesse
issue is in his et puis c'est tout à
fait vitale en forêt parce que c'est
plus sympa les états unis leur maman a
pris une chance maman a dit je veux
aller au canada
sur chaque homme si ça a été mieux pour
moi de là puis est enceinte est venu ici
elle a pris vraiment un lip fait elle
seule tout ça car cette personne
lafon 10 elle a fondé son avis que je
vienne ici fini on ne divague handicap à
dispo grave on continue tac tac tac
avait confiance en moi
puis le chien gars shanghai fauteuil
roulant oui c'est une grave faute aux
danois oui mais ça ne devrait pas nuire
à toute identité que marmara sacrifie
pour vouloir me donner tout à fait pitié
séparant tobago familial puis citée par
as d'en parler on se quitte là dessus
qu'il faut blâmer t on parle des stigmas
on parle de notation parlent de
perception que quand les gens envers les
gens avec un handicap c'est tout on
parle de sens à lille c'est mon port
juste toujours ma mort c'est la personne
la plus forte au monde parce que elle
voulait vrai au canada personnes
voulaient aller convenu
mon père il ya du vent qui ont fait ça a
été handicapé il ya dit non je peux pas
je peux pas ça serait trop de maman en
fait c'est pas grave je continue à faire
tout seul au canada elles avaient tous
les arts profité au monde de dire non
j'ai arrêté de bananes mais je pense
mind alors pu m'apporter je pense qu'ils
ont des devoirs l'handicap a sitôt la
plume avorter elle tout était contre
elle puis elle a quand même fait elle a
percé comme moi dans ma tête mon enfant
est handicapé quoi tu t'abandonnes comme
friable par le plus beau je ferais mais
je trouve aussi l'idée que ça va être
l'eau vous ça va être difficile kaká
real même choqué tabac pour des
connexions même chose qu'on parlait des
relations ouais dit sari l'eau mais non
c'est possible que cela mais oui mais ça
mais séparément ce qui est on voit c'est
bruno senna pilote quand la fa qui est
drôle quand j'ai commencé à devenir plus
en plus à une personnalité connue y est
revenu tout d'un coup diakonia porte
puis a fait un salut c moi ton c'est moi
ton pas joignable tous les noms n'ont
comme c'était pas ça la cote est stable
ils ont deux best fond le domaine mais
c'est vrai comme si le petit globe
tu voulais pas prendre la chance et
travailler fort pour même si à travers
leur travail
tempo la marque divorce métal les
standards du temps scolaire au moins tu
abandonnes et on a enfin comme il n'y a
pas d' excuses
il n'y a pas d'excusé pour moi n'y a pas
d' excuses c'est pour ça peu importe mon
enfant voir comment je vais aller me
dois faire de mon mieux d'être quelque
chose que j'ai pu
parce que je trouve ça moi je trouve ça
marche car je serais passé dans la vie
même
je veux pas trouver d'excusés comme je
peux comprendre que à sa vie difficile
au fait que ma mère si tu devais la fin
abbas et du site sa copie de cd v à la
fin tout seul attaque menée par imagine
tu élever un enfant seule avec mon
handicap
ça doit être un groupe i had a comme un
battant qui me donne un grand temps
qu'ils me en tant qu en tant qu il est
incroyable puis cara computer par les
fous rires je pense que vous avez évité
à beauvais par sa mère comme selon moi
elle a fait une belle job mais oui pis
c'est à chaque jour m donne de l'amour
un dicastère mon chéri et toupie j'ai
pas j'ai 24 ans j'ai peu de moments où
c'est plus parce que j'avais un handicap
gibbons moment où quand j'avais 8 ans
puis j'ai maman pour moi dans mes bras
elle faisait à des skinheads s'en va
c'est aussi pour ça j'ai pas je trouve
ça moche d'abandonner quelque chose
quand quand a commencé mais c'est mais
un film élèves l'inversion succès
tellement courageux damas et c'est extra
c'est super humain vraiment c'est un
truc de super-héros faire seul vraiment
c'est toute la famille devient bien
fleuries s'est échappé au pire mais elle
a pris la chance ne s'y dit non je
continue et je continue j'ai des
frissons quand les sacrifices qu'elle a
dit avoir les les commentaires négatifs
canadien avant parce que moi tant il ya
peu mais je te regarde pas mal de nos
véhicules à laver küttel a plus les
commentaires qu'elle a dû avoir toqué à
garder car son enfant est en fait en
fauteuil roulant ou quoi que ce soit
mais puis à la condition à sourire à
continuer à mai
ck c'est quand tu réalises que tu es
parents ont fait beaucoup de sacrifices
pour toi qui étaient reconnaissants pour
percer mais passaient leur temps à magna
parce que moi mon but au début c'était
que je sois heureux maintenant mon but
c'est que ma famille soit que mama
reçoit bien évidemment parce que tout ce
qu'elle a fait des sacrifices café c'est
juste quand on la voit et il ya ce
week-end a fait un documentaire de
douzaine de minutes sur toi pour
l'avocat membre théâtre là d'une femme
ultra solide droite
en même temps on était tellement
heureuse qui avait des caméras à peine
trois minutes avant que le cam à son
arrivée ouais c'est vulgaire michel
tassé vu le gars micheline tellement
mais c'est juste aujourd'hui j'ai dit je
m'en vais je m'en vais à montréal en
entrevue série death qui a été déposée
métier non non non c'est une croûte
ces beautés jusqu'à une femme c'est une
chanteuse incroyable t elle a adopté
deux jeunes enfants élections qui
avaient monté 19ème space et puis qui
sait que si mambo lorsque ses enfants
dans une famille unie et permanente qui
créént ici je connais pas le background
particulier mais tu te dis site étant la
dame chance parce que je demande qu'ils
ont imaginé une proportion quand même
plus
je serai pas les statistiques mais c'est
clair que c'est en fauteuil roulant non
si tu t'en prends un physique ou quoi
que ce soit pete est alors [ __ ] c'est
un peu peur ou quoi que ce soit puisse
fêter cet effet adopté chez sap est fait
je l'aï en réalisant d'adopter ce bond
qui on travaille plus c'est sûr parce
que c'est pas dit qui depuis août un
imagine de grands fauteuils par
contumace le fais je comprends pas comme
moi je vous montre moi je vois pas le
problème
parce que je vis j'aimerais tellement ça
je serais un bip est juste une journée
qui le voit tous ces problèmes puis j'ai
pas l'impression n'avait pas ce nom
vraiment vraiment je comprends pas comme
on dirait que c'est ça que moi je suis
en fauteuil et je vois pas le problème
pourquoi je rate pas beaucoup de chance
à prendre connaître avant ses avants à
voir avant avant un moment
quand j'avais 19 ans je rappelle à eibar
je vous dis moi qui me demandait est-ce
que c'était parti
pendant lequel j'ai des amis qui
m'attendent à une table puis j'ai
demandé pourquoi je sais quoi c'est pas
je sais pas il y en a beaucoup travaillé
c'est sûr je me pose la question moi
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour régler
ce problème qu'est ce que comment je
peux dès stigmatisé le fait que
quelqu'un en fauteuil il ya sa place de
porte ou est tu le fais je pense que tu
le fais déjà c'est bien jean newport
mais je pense que tu le fais déjà c'est
bien ou du mans était sur la ligne de le
faire de plus en plus le métier pitot en
fait ce qui est un fils il te prie la
problématique l'attaquer de front le
prix dans tes mains et il s'était
construite en même temps plateforme ou
dans l'art instagram plutôt les gens qui
te suivent pileux grâce à ce petit jeu
n'est pas que plus l'on ne tenait pas
que l'homme est il juste et fait
remarquer en plus par ton propre petit
prof magna ton propre chemin et belle
petite fenêtre mon appart facteur
déclenchant même d'augmentations mai
c'est quand même dit un obstacle qu'est
ce que je fais je fais face à
pragmatique je fais de quoi puisque ça
en jambes ça fait un effet boule de
neige
je pense une des raisons pourquoi je
voulais faut que c'est cette année à
cette année il avait pensé à le bassin
québécois tout ce qui
pas de casse tout ce qui est entrevue
tout ce qui est perçant et et public je
vais apprendre la culture québécoise si
je connaissais pas julie snyder
j'avais jamais cette équipe mais je
pouvais pas la visualiser chez moi je
pouvais pas palard cash pourrait pas le
visualiser pourquoi parce que je voulais
rien savoir je voulais pas savoir parce
que c'est pas quelque chose que je me
voyais dedans mais je me suis comporté à
rentrer dans ma communauté
tu vois ces grands dit que je me suis
dit je me suis forcé à me rentrer dedans
tu es parce que je me sens à l'extra
exclu puis je me suis forcé à rentrer
dans la communauté parce que je me
disais je vis ici vaut mieux que
j'apprends la plus qu'est ce qui se
passe ici et c'est l'échangé ici pour
peut-être changé ailleurs après versus à
bout des internats du monde ça va
marcher mais disons que c'est un nom peu
je suis vient du québec demande il ya
beaucoup de monde qui pensent que je
suis des états unis ou que demande comme
les voisins qui voit des vieux deux mois
pim dans mon essai gueulatis canetti
yayi traçage comme c'est vous c'est moi
aussi beaucoup d'heures
j'ai toujours allez salut cousin 15e en
salle et non onze comme j'aime mieux
jamais vu ça comme on fera passer un
cousin c'est vrai quand même on est
cousin on est tous cousins ça c'est pour
sa famille se trouve c'est je me suis
comme forcer à rentrer dans le bassin
québécois parce que je veux plus de
représentations si moi je commence enfin
quand il y en a d'autres qui vont faire
c'est un bon début puis le monde qui
nous écoutent it suivent où ils font
quoi il checke quoi déjà fort que c'est
le temps de plier tout est truqué
moi je suis plus sereine à g c'est au
bout de l'effort
w o des grecs puis j'ai commencé tik tok
j'ai prévu mais j'ai commencé tout à
coup il va aussi tous les sites écrit ou
dit bernard thibault tout les emplois de
trouver google sites web non je veux
commencer
quand je pense que je devrais commencer
parce que je pense qu'il tolère que le
sait ouais d'opinion business donner des
conférences
mais je donne des conférences dans les
écoles mais j'ai peu de sites web à base
si je veux pas moment non plus présent
c'est d'avoir étages multiples et
d'heures allez on sait quand je vous dis
quand j'écris mon dos j'écris beaucoup
non beaucoup de monde
billon est tangible j'écris ou devant y
arrive ça va demander aux autres stars
du sans fil sont rendus jusqu'à
maintenant nous créer une page weezy
collaboratif exactement dit quelqu un s
à lui s'il ya quelqu'un qui a bein euh
de trop dans la journée six à vingt
minutes de trop que piccoli genre tout
ce que je fais puis maastricht plaisir
surtout
après pour restituer soeur je pense que
je t'ai vu pour le restant de ma vie
pour rien s'emporte désormais ouais tout
ça pour toi je suis plus serein ce ta g
si jamais vous voulez quelque chose puis
si j'arrive dans les questions si
j'essaye de toujours répondre à toutes
les questions de tout le monde je peux
assez gros pour que je manque des
questions mais je réponds à tout le
monde si j'arrive à être question quoi
que ce soit n'hésitez pas bien cool vous
dise un plaisir merci merci un coup
merci beaucoup merci merci d'avoir
écouté ses podcasts jusqu'à la fin de ce
pas que vous avez apprécié la
conversation ça prouve que vous êtes de
réelles fans de conversation et du
sans-fil pas de casser on vous remercie
vraiment beaucoup
si vous voulez avoir plus de contenus
plus de conversation c'est sûr
pétillante que ça se passait sur petra
non seulement on met tous les podcasts
en ligne au moment où est ce qu'on les
tombes donc on a beaucoup de semaine
d'avant sur le pga mais on fait aussi
des encore moins de filtres qui sont
exclusifs aux membres béthunois ce que
on parle d'homme n'est que l'émoi de la
conversation qu'ont bien d'avoir ce
qu'on met un peu plus en profondeur dans
certains sujets qu'on voulait aborder ou
qu'on a abordé pendant le podcast donc
allez sur notre page recréer le lien
vers ce havre dans la description du
podcast qui remercie encore une fois de
nous avons écouté jusqu'à la fin